girl you are just a Vibe tonight thank
you you get cooler and cooler every time
that's not true it is so true just take
it in I hope your girls are taking it in
too I think they're enjoyable
she is very cool if you ladies don't
know just saying they're like they're
like oh my gosh
oh my God girls we need to have a chat
now let's chat come chat with me SJP
what were the easiest and the most
difficult parts of slipping back into
Sarah Sanderson I think the easiest part
was being on the set with Ben and Kathy
every day singing flying trying to
recall and remember what we did and why
yes
and I think the hardest part is just
masks and filmmaking you know covid
restrictions and guidelines that you
really want to honor it just separates
you from people I think one of the best
parts of making a movie is the human
exchange that happens on a set you know
you're with your crew all the time
they're a family away from your other
family and so the hardest part is just
feeling separate from people that you
typically are you're all over each other
all day long but if that's what was
required for us to get together and make
the movie we were willing to do it and
the easy part is just being you know
back among this group and getting to
tell another chapter in the story and
working with Anne and you know the great
musical department and getting to sing
again and flying flying flying
you love to fly you're even up in the
air reading your newspapers doing the
break yeah yeah yeah yeah I did that on
the first movie this movie The Flying
the um the technology has changed the
engineering and the way they fly people
now answer device that you're flying on
yes I'm on a Swiffer Kathy's on a Roomba
and Beck got the broom yeah totally 2022
y'all she was screaming at us you know
get a room get a broom and there was
only one room so she got it that's
winning not bad
um but yeah it's a it's a joy and you
know it was cold and in the middle of
winter and we were you know up on the
northern part of the Eastern Seaboard so
it was cold but it was definitely worth
it and fans are gonna just enjoy this
ride so much and we're awesome so God's
ears oh honey they will enjoy it and
we're also gonna enjoy it and just like
that you were chasing fans with a little
shot of the script so disable read on
Wednesday oh my gosh season one was
about grief season two is it going to be
a place of love two is about uh
Brilliance and rebound and laughter and
finding laughter more easily for people
who might have experienced grief and
more of our new cast members who we love
and more Aiden could be could be well
you know I mean I can't be I can't be
like cryptic about it
I know I'm very excited
[Music]